president Trump confirms big changes are
in store for Air Force One he told CBS
Evening News anchor that's Jeff Glor in
Scotland that the new model the
presidential plane will be updated both
inside and out
can we talk about Air Force one for a
second yeah so we want to the goal is to
repaint it to redo it
no four years they've wanted to order
new Air Force One you know Air Force one
is two planes right one plane right I
think most people know that FS one is
two planes and no president has been
able to make the right deal they haven't
been able to make a deal to do and you
know Air Force One is 30 years old and
it shouldn't be and so I don't even know
that up because it's a long time to
build and we just started the process
but I was able to save 1.5 billion
dollars and order a new one for the
country but if your vision is for naught
no powder blue it's the it's a red white
and blue plane a new plane when it comes
in Air Force one which will be largely
for future presidents because by the
time it gets built I hate to say this
it's gonna be a long time it's a very
complex project but by the time it gets
built you're gonna have many presidents
hopefully use it and enjoy it but Boeing
gave us a good deal and we were able to
take that but I said I wonder if we
should use the same baby blue color it's
and we're not you know what colors were
using take a guess
red white and blue red white and blue
Air Force One is going to be incredible
it's going to be the top of the line the
top in the world and it's going to be
red white and blue which i think is
appropriate and he also wants to get a
bigger bed in there too I think that's a
good idea cuz right right I've never
been on it but I'm told it's a double
you've been on it John I'm told it's a
double size bed or a queen-size bed yeah
it's not very big but it's you feel like
you're flying in an office you don't
know that you're in a plane so it's
pretty sweet Dave so iconic I know I
read plane that I like that powder-blue
to Jeff speaks with President Trump
again tomorrow this time at the White
House you can see the interview tomorrow
night on the CBS Evening News and
Thursday right here on CBS this morning
boy they got a lot to talk a lot of time